Christina Hoff Sommers
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been too long we go way back
we know wait who used to be a lot on
politically incorrect right I remember
you run when your first book came out
which was called who stole feminism yes
and it's so funny I was thinking because
my show was called politically incorrect
I thought I was gonna defeat political
correctness only has gotten worse yes I
failed miserably at that and as far as
who stole feminism whoever stole it that
that kind of got worse too didn't it it
got worse I thought it was gonna be easy
to get it back yeah it's proved
impossible and feminism is supposed to
be about equality between the sexes
mutuality friendship civility yet its
captive to a small group of very intense
eccentrics who think men are the enemy
and that the the look the goal of
feminism wasn't was to overcome male
chauvinism I became a feminist in this
70s because I didn't like male
chauvinism I still don't but the answer
is not female chauvinism right and now
the movement is captive to female
chauvinist who want to just emphasize
how bad men are toxic masculinity and
and somehow you know people like you
maybe you don't agree with everything
you say but how did you get to be the
the right winger I mean you're a
Democrat right you're Jewish PhD from
Brandeis yes okay you've been published
in the New England Journal of Medicine
yeah I read about what happened to you
it was in Oberlin College any colleges
I'm a frequent college lecturer and when
I have been lecturing for years and
usually I'd go to debate and spar with
some women's studies professors because
I occupy a different position and sort
of a feminist theory but now these days
I go and we don't it's not the women
studies people it's the students who
come the activists to demonstrate they
set up safe rooms I spoke at safe rooms
from you from me and I have to have
bodyguards at Oberlin
I had a detail of police what did they
also have a therapy dog yes here's the
thing
they learned from you because yes no a
young woman well they had the safe room
setup and 30 women and a therapy dog led
to the safe space I triggered a dog I
feel bad about the dog yeah yeah see I
mean you mentioned things that I thought
feminism was when it started out one of
the things I thought it was about was
strength exactly you know wonder woman
yeah strong they love wonder woman women
but hear me roar you hear me right
but what happened I'm asking you okay
the fragility it's not just women let's
be honest it's thinking couch feminism
what fainting couch women would like
rights on on an elegant chairs right yes
sir in the in the presence of male
vulgarity well what I mean we can't
handle that we want to be in the
military you know we want it for be
running the world
well I'm sorry you can handle it male
impropriety now I'm not saying that we
we shouldn't have strong rules against
sexual harassment of course I fought for
that but that doesn't mean policing men
for a little minor you know can I read
that this is Bernie Sanders had to start
his campaign for president this time
fending off these accusations that
someone in his campaign had committed
horrible crimes not horrible crimes but
sexual crimes are it was part of it was
lumped in with the knew someone hurt it
was not that bad someone he said can I
touch your hair and she said yes and
then he did it for longer than she
wanted and pet maybe he was touching her
all day it was wrong but things happen
that if things happen that are wrong but
here's listen to another Bernie Sanders
campaigns that said she had to stare a
room one night with male staffers this
happens on a campaign they were on a
shoestring budget
this is what she said I was shaking with
fear literally I remember thinking to
myself what am I going to do go to sleep
these are not escaped cons your in the
world
these are Bernie Sanders I know and this
is not what feminism is supposed to be
but right there there are these
professors and they pass along these
messages that we're all traumatized
we're all fragile were diminished under
this patriarchal oppressive system this
is madness American women arguably are
among the freest most self-determining
in history I was a fertile I was a
philosophy and it's a very moment where
we we have this opportunity for just
profound equality with men and to take
on running of the world with men at that
very moment we start giving especially
undergraduate women at the more elite
colleges we start giving them the
message that their victims they're
fragile they're they need not equality
with men but protection from these toxic
masculinity monza
here's Joe Biden's Lucy Flores I was
taking deep breaths preparing myself to
make my case to the crowd I felt two
hands on my shoulders I froze froze from
that why is the vice president on States
touching me he's human sometimes humans
touch other people I get touched
sometimes I don't want people thank you
touches
I I was mortified morning this Rises I I
didn't wash my hair today and the Vice
President is smelling it now we've hit a
nerve with the crowd he proceeded to
plant a big slow kiss on the back of my
head my brain couldn't process what was
happening process what's an old man in
the back and on the campus
they used the language of catastrophe to
characterize like day to day life on the
campus one young woman I was at
University of Pennsylvania and she she
said oh I was mini raped a guy walked by
and said nice legs microaggression mini
rape microaggressions thing so if a man
so you have to define microaggressions
and these are like minor insults but
somehow remind you of your diminished
place in the patriotic as a system so
apparently using the phrase you guys
women can't handle that and monster
monster
so it's trivializes genuine enemy to
movement I mean look we owe why say
we've been Oh women a lot because we're
a young species
we're basically still savages and women
have borne the brunt of that yes
we want to applaud opposing that yes I
know what you know but it just goes to
crazy places now I know I know you have
said you think that male privilege is a
conspiracy theory no no I think that men
have privileges but so do women right
and I think if you look at contemporary
America what you see is a complicated
mix of advantages and burdens for each
sex for example women are far more
privileged in the classroom young women
and girls are far more privileged than
boys boys are barely tolerated these
days in many classrooms they just not a
lot of schools of Education have our
captive to these paranoid theories about
toxic masculinity and they think that
the slightest show of male bravado so a
little boy you know can be thrown out of
suspended because he bit like a poptart
into the shape of a gun and he was
thrown as well I know the thing with the
cherry stem look also men die they die
in workplace accident 92% of people who
die in workplace accidents men murder
victim 78% suicide 78% 85% go into
combat for the same crime
63% longer sentences if you're a man so
yeah I get your point that there's
there's bad things to being a man - yeah
it's for both sexes but what about the
pay gap now this is probably where your
most controversial controversial it's
not the any responsible economist who
looks at the gap what you see is that on
average women do if you look at all the
men and all the women in the country
working full time it turns out there's
about a 20 to 23 percent gap now is that
because of discrimination well people
have tried to find the discrimination
but at first you have to do the proper
controls and ask what did they study in
school what is their what job are they
in you know how many hours a week
they work how long do they commute how
dangerous is the job and when you factor
in these various things the wage gap
begins to narrow to the point of
vanishing but some of it is because
women they say don't negotiate as well
as men for their own behalf well you
know some Harvard economists like
Claudia Goldin have looked into that and
think it that doesn't explain the gap
most of the gap is explained by it's a
very high end where men are willing to
work just punishing hours on weekends
and long in law firms and in finance and
that hasn't well women do that too of
course they don't do it as much maybe
they don't do it as much now you could
say it's unfair because women are maybe
taking care of children or mean women
don't have the liberty to do that now
that's true and that's an interesting
discussion but notice that's not because
employers are cheating them it's because
men and women do behave slightly
different differently in private life
even if it is and I think it is somewhat
the case that women are not as adept at
negotiating for themselves it isn't
coming upon them to learn how to do it
thank you
but all college majors so if you want to
make a lot of money
you should major that we know this the
highest you know most remunerative
college majors like petroleum
engineering you will make more money if
you are now the majority of the majors
in petroleum engineering are males very
few females and women are murdered by
dicta and being that also metallurgy
naval architecture very few women but
you make money women are over here in
early childhood education fields they
find rewarding and Social Work and
society society has shitty priorities
but then you can try to change the
priorities it but but don't say we're
being cheated out of our salary it's a
complicated issue so what I try to do on
the fence planners is to show people
that women are going to be helped by
truth and accurate analyses of problems
and we just don't have that right now we
have a lot of spin and hyperbole you
gotta go get with my therapy dog but
thank you so much for coming by and
come explain enjoy great to see you
again
[Applause]
you